I don't feel like there is enough sort
of opportunity for these women to
actually go out there and realize that
it is a doable job there are quite a few
women out there that do want to become
electricians employers less than two
percent two percent of the industry
that's the thing you don't see it a lot
so is it a thing where we need to be
pushing that more in schools and opening
up and saying well this isn't just a
thing for guys well so I actually think
women don't do it because it's hard do
you think so yes I think that I watch
them build the building next door no it
looks hard and I think we don't have the
strength to do it good though over time
we definitely no no have you are you an
athlete I'm not an athlete but I do
train yeah but I just I mean you see the
numbers they when they left we can't
keep up with that but